i'm very proud that we were able to
deploy the first ever clinically
approved cova vaccine here in this
country
and delivered 60 million doses of three
different vaccines
into 39 million arms as of midnight last
night
i can confirm that we now have given a
first dose
of vaccine to three quarters of the
adult population of the united kingdom
lots of people stop me and ask me
how we did all this so i thought i'd
take the time
to set it out as i see it i believe that
the uk's vaccination success story is
not an accident
it's a result of the approach that we
took decisions that we made
decisions that have been made before and
i want to look both at what worked and
what didn't work because one of the
things i've noticed in government is
that when something goes well
people seem to think everything went
well and it didn't
i want to take a step back and reflect
on this
extraordinary project the extraordinary
team the vaccine heroes as i call them
and the extraordinary response of the
public because
ultimately this project is
a project that everybody is part of